la toxicité des vaccins à l'opinion donc
on retrouve en réalité entre 50 et 60%
de complotiste dans l'opinion française
quand on arrive à des sujets santé c'est
énorme
en réalité de l'internet n'a pas tué le
complotisme internet a fait exploser a
beaucoup beaucoup nourri le complotisme
c'est le contraire de ce qu'on espérait
en 1995 où on pensait que tout le monde
aurait la bonne information au bon
moment en réalité le numérique a
augmenté le complotisme française merci
beaucoup de réactions de nos internautes
je peux malheureusement pas toutes les
citer mais résiste pas au plaisir de
laisser le dernier mot à claudius 15 qui
dit moi je suis volontaire pour
embrasser une asiatique
c'est très bien comme ça on change de
sujet si vous voulez bien
la jeune crée ta thune berg militante
pour le climat était donc invité ce
matin du collège des commissaires
européens et ce soir elle publiera sur
le site du figaro une tribune
ce sera à 22 heures je le dis pour
laurent alexandre qui meurt d'impatience
et on la retrouvera également cette
tribune dans le figaro de demain la
jeune suédoise
une fois de plus vitupère les
responsables politiques occidentaux en
expliquant que l'idée d'arriver à zéro
émission dette d'ici à 2050 ça équivaut
à capituler à baisser les bras il faut
agir tout de suite dit elle
est-ce qu'elle a raison hervé nathan
parce que c'est plus facile à dire qu'à
faire
les deux mon colonel elle a raison alors
d'abord je trouve que greta turberg
qu'au bout d'un moment on commence à se
lasser
d'ailleurs qu'il serait bien quand même
que je sais que le journaliste aime les
bons clients d'accord et que c'est une
excellente cliente comme on dit dans le
jargon s'exprime elle part elle arrive à
incarner les choses et elle dit que
c'est à dire de l'élite comme il a dit
quelque chose à l'époque mais il ya
peut-être d'autres jeunes
moi je ne reproche pas au fait que c'est
un sondage parce que je suis d'une
génération qui commençait la politique à
15 heures donc de toutes façons
voilà il d'expérience je sais qu'on peut
trouver d'autres peut-être autres jeunes
de 15 16 ou 17 ans choqué les dix sept
ans maintenant 1,17 je pense complet
trouvé d'autres têtes d'affiché même si
l'effet de base est donc mais sur le
message je pense qu'en tout cas
ponctuellement sur ce qui concerne la la
volonté l'absence de volonté européenne
de prendre des actes concrets pour
démarrer dès maintenant le la transition
douce vers la transition climatique
elle a raison c'est à dire que pour le
moment compte tenu des déséquilibres
actuels politique qu'il ya entre les
différents pouvoirs européens
l'objectif est zéro émission d'ici à
2050 ça reste un voeu pieux c'est à dire
que derrière ce n'est accompagnée
d'aucune mesure d'aucune politique parce
que il ya aucun consensus en europe et
ce que je crains à ce moment là je lui
donne raison
ce que je sais que je crains c'est que
l'europe soit à la fois encore le
continent de l'impuissance de la même
façon qui a été un puissant ville et
nature qui la même façon que la
stratégie de lisbonne si pour ceux qui
se souviennent qu'ils devaient faire de
l'union européenne
la zone la plus productive et la plus
inventive d'europe en 2010 n'est pas
arrivé au saint lô
l'iem de ses objectifs parce qu'on avait
décidé que ce serait un objectif et
c'est un nouveau la même chose qui est
en train de se profiler et qu'on avait
pris aucune mesure concrète n'ait aucune
mesure contraignante
voilà donc 200 cadres là je lui
donnerait raison n'ayant pas encore lu
et l'asi la tribune avant voici kergoz
dont quelques extraits elle se met à la
place des jeunes
je dois confesser que ces danses d'un
système ambiant je n'ai parlé que de
greenberg alors que cette chronique est
cosignée par trois autres jeunes
mais il est vrai que ceux ci n'ont pas
le même degré de notoriété
donc elles estiment ils estiment tous
ces jeunes que la situation est
inacceptable et puis il ya aussi une
attaque assez directe vis-à-vis des
politiciens tant que vous ne prendrez
pas la situation au sérieux
nous vous sommes monde de rentrer chez
vous d'étudier l'effet est de revenir
lorsque vous aurez fait votre devoir
dionne de musi c'est un ton très
désagréable mais non je ne sais pas si
mes c est là un ton amusé il a aussi dit
elle elle a aussi parlé de façon
extrêmement comme sa cinglante
en fait j'ai l'impression que ça peut
vraiment est la raison est la raison 95%
des personnes vous diront qu'elle a
raison sur le fond que l'on va on va à
notre perte au cours à notre perte et
que tout ça est très juste et à combat
un combat juste et qu'elle mène le mieux
possible mais sur la forme pour susciter
l'adhésion en tout cas de notre société
et je pense qu'il ya quelque chose dans
son discours techniciste qui qui qui moi
me heurte à chaque fois qu'ils
m'empêchent de la rejoindre complètement
j'ai l'impression qu'elle est allée elle
n'a pas accès à la beauté du monde elle
parle de la biodiversité elle a un
discours de chiffres de l'armee sme et
de façon elle n'a pas du tout elle fait
pas raisonner le sentiment romantique de
la nature et le sentiment qu'il faut
préserver cette chose là parce que c'est
un cadeau qui nous est vraiment fait et
elle elle en parle comme d'une belle
tout de suite aimé de la virulence un
combat de façon très coercitif et par
ailleurs je trouve que régis debray dans
son dernier essai sur l'écologie est
excellent parce qu'il explique comment
aujourd'hui on a inversé le
on est sortis de l'ère chrétienne dans
le sens où avant on avancer tous d'un
des bus vers une fin vers un objectif
commun et aujourd'hui le combat de cette
jeunesse là c'est le combat d'une
sauvegarde et et peut-être d'un retour
en arrière mais que là l'histoire est
devenue horizontale elle est plus
verticale elle est plus aspirer par une
ambition commune est dans une espèce de
résistance de crispation et d'angoissé
très profondes qui fait que que le temps
s'arrête qu'on est rentré dans une
religion la religion l'écologie non
seulement les internautes réagissent
mais ils votent aussi sur des questions
que nous vous proposons dont celle ci
trouvez-vous que great attenberg a fait
avancer la cause écologique c'est non à
68% et quelque chose me dit laurent
l'exemple que vous êtes assez d'accord
avec ce oui moi je me dis je me méfie de
du discours d attenberg puisque elle a
dit à plusieurs reprises qu'elle était à
titre personnel contre nucléaire voyez
si on prend hier les chiffres officiels
pour la france on a intégralement
remplacées hier fessenheim qu'on a fermé
et fessenheim les 900 mégawatts de
fessenheim produisent 4 grammes de co2
par kilowattheure ce été intégralement
compensé par des centrales à fuel qui
produisent 1515 grammes de co2 par
kilowattheure c'est à dire 400 fois plus
voyez que derrière le discours des bons
sentiments ont fini par faire fermer du
nucléaire est derrière on augmente
considérablement la quantité de co2 qui
est produite vous rendez compte que on
remplace aujourd'hui fessenheim part du
des centrales à fuel qui produisent 400
fois plus de réchauffement climatique
pour la même quantité d'énergie
il faut faire très attention alors le
discours très véhément de solberg
on en a quand même retrouvé les
l'origine politique politicienne
idéologique dans son fameux papier
décembre quand elle a dit que le
réchauffement climatique était lié au
patriarcat raciste colonialiste
oppressif c'est un texte écrit ce n'est
pas un disque oracle qu'il faut
démanteler
donc on est passé en réalité de la
défense des coquelicots au gauchisme
intersectionnelle le plus le plus
extrémiste donc l'origine
gic de la violence de greta sonberg il
est lié au fait que ce n'est pas un ce
n'est pas une écologiste c'est en
réalité une gauchiste parce que excusez
moi je ne vois pas en quoi l'homme blanc
serait raciste et colonialiste et
responsables du réchauffement climatique
en 2020 le pays qui produit le moins de
co2 par unité de richesses produites
parmi les grands pays au monde
c la france y arriver hier il y avait
évidemment grâce au nucléaire
mais si vous savez faire baisser le
réchauffement climatique sans nucléaire
moi je suis je suis preneur de la delà
de 2000 produits ce pouvoir fait six
fois plus de co2 non d'accord mais il
faut regarder la tendance
ils sont toujours à 838 en mêlée fermée
d'ici 2038 bel et bien pas mal la
situation en 2010 n'ont donné aussi en
train de remplacer leurs ventes ont
certes il parle ou l'éolien
en réalité je suis c'est ça ou ne pas le
voir ce assez déçu voulait pas voir 8,6
fois plus hervé l'allemagne aujourd'hui
8,6 fois plus de réchauffement lillois
de la crise entre en bourse
ils ont une vraie industrie c'est parce
que son cd industrialise a récolté paru
par unité d'énergie produite par global
board paris droite heures ils ont
toujours à vue devant 800 iso
merci mx1 d'échangés comme jeudi monde
passionnant dans le fossé la mise à
l'heure d'en débattre nos internautes
greta est beaucoup trop agressive nous
diola donc je n'écoute pas alors que
jean-michel nous dit bravo à cette jeune
greta si chez moi convaincu et si on
écoutait les scientifiques
au lieu d'écouter une gamine
vu de kevin climat et coronavirus pointe
le même problème il faut agir rapidement
mais les politiques sont généralement
lent le mot de la fin sur ce sujet
cercles achats de roma déjà la première
violence qui s'exerce et la violence
effectivement des humains sur la nature
donc moi ça ne dérange pas que une jeune
fille effectivement et des propos assez
virulent si elle secoue un peu le
cocotier parce qu'effectivement on a du
mal à écouter les scientifiques
donc si elle permet que cette écoute
elle soit plus le plus large ça ne me
pose aucun problème sur le fond je pense
que en fait il ya une autre question qui
n'est pas posée parce que les chiffres
c'est bien ça fixe un cap ça permet de
mobiliser les forces mais la vraie
question aussi c'est de se dire
finalement qu'on va pas pouvoir
continuer à vivre de la même façon et je
trouve que cette question là n'est pas
posée elle et elle est vraiment noyer
soul sous les objectifs parce qu'au fin
fond il faut qu'on que nous mode de vie
se modifie que nos modes de production
se modifie j il s'agit pas de parler de
décroissance mais il va falloir qu'on
avance sur ce chemin différemment et je
voudrais citer parce que je suis tombé
dessus en préparant cette émission un
rapport d'une ong qui s'appelle notre
affaire c'est juste à titre d'exemple
qu'à regarder 25 entreprises des grands
groupes français à vocation
internationale depuis 2010 est chaque
groupe chaque entreprise doit publier un
plan dit de vigilance et qui pour
identifier les risques que son activité
fait peser sur l'environnement notamment
est donc l april group bnp temps total
bouygues sur l'e25 étudiée il y en avait
que 10 qui avait dit pardon dix
entreprises n'intégrait pas du tout le
climat dans leurs plans alors certains
publient plan mehdi s'intégrer pas du
tout le climat est alors sans compter qu
aucune n'avait mise en place de mesures
vraiment susceptibles de faire changer
significativement les émotions les
émissions autres autre point c'est que
je pense que quand je parlais de
modification de mode de vie nous mêmes
nous devons changer
je pense que ça la conscience n'est pas
encore du tout du tout généraliser
diffusé à titre d'exemple qu'il venait
pour la génération autonome et regardez
il ya 80% du français qui changent leur
smartphone alors que leur smartphone
n'est pas cassé autre exemple la mode la
mode avec ses collections qui se
renouvelle tous les quinze jours les
écrans qu'ils deviennent de plus en plus
grand de plus en plus performant et je
comprends pas il ya quelque chose que je
ne comprends pas juste pour finir
là-dessus pardon guillaume c'est que là
on est en pleine campagne municipale je
comprends pas pourquoi dans chaque ville
puisqu'on nous dit qu'il faut plus
acheter comme ça mais qu'il faut réparer
pourquoi on a pas dans chaque ville un
endroit où on nous aide à réparer nos
appareils pourquoi on a pas un endroit
dans chaque ville où il ya des
ressourceries on peut acheter des
vêtements d'occasion
je trouve qu'il ya plein de choses dont
on a besoin pour changer nos modes de
vie qui ne sont pas aujourd'hui mise en
place ça prouve bien qu'il ya pas cette
conscience là et que si on n'agit pas
aussi là et bien ça ne servira à rien
tout merci beaucoup le message est passé
on franchit l'atlantique si vous le
voulez bien
c'était le super mardi vous savez cette
journée où les primaires sont très
nombreuses donc tous les états unis
l'objectif cette année est évidemment de
choisir le candidat démocrate